new this morning crash tests on two
popular SUVs reveal serious safety
concerns the Insurance Institute for
Highway Safety gave the 2018 Ford
Explorer and Jeep Grand Cherokee poor
ratings in front passenger crash tests
the tests showed protections built into
the driver's side aren't necessarily
there for front seat passengers the
agency tested eight SUVs only three of
them earned the top score of good three
others were rated acceptable Kris Van
Cleave is in Washington with the
eye-opening results Kris good morning
good morning now this crash test focuses
on what happens when just one part of
the front end hits something at forty
miles an hour the Insurance Institute
estimates 25% of the serious injuries
and deaths that result from front-end
crashes come out of these kinds of
accidents the 2018 Ford Explorer rated
poor because its structure collapsed
intruding as much as 15 inches into the
SUV resulting in a high likelihood of
injuries to the front passengers right
hip and left lower leg Ford insists the
Explorer is safe saying we continually
make improvements to our vehicles to
help our customers stay safe on the road
David zoobi is the Insurance Institute
for Highway Safety's chief research
officer as we are observing that some of
the countermeasures or the design
changes that automakers were making on
the on the driver's side weren't
necessarily making themselves to the
right side of the vehicle
watch the passenger side crash dummy's
head when the 2018 Jeep Grand Cherokee
crashes it hits the dashboard through
the airbag the side airbag does not
deploy and the door opens allowing the
dummy's head to go outside the SUV the
poor performance resulted in possible
head injuries the vehicles safety cage
intruded into the cabin by up to 10
inches
fiat-chrysler makes the Jeep and says
all its vehicles meet or exceed federal
safety standards and are engineered to
address real-world driving situations no
single test measures overall vehicle
safety my advice to people who are
shopping for a new vehicle is that
they've got better choices
the 2019 Kia Sorento scored good after
it was redesigned to better protect
front passengers it is the only SUV of
the eight tested to earn the IIHS
highest overall rating top safety pick+
both the Ford Explorer and the Jeep
Grand Cherokee are older designs Ford
tells us it expects its all-new 2024 to
Explorer to do better in this test when
it's launched next year IIHS expects the
redesigned Jeep Grand Cherokee we'll
also do better when that vehicle
launches up north or an important
information Chris thank you so much